[Musique]
bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement bonjour et bienvenue dans
les grands débats c'est un moment
important de la vie politique et
parlementaire chaque semaine les députés
interpellent les ministres sur
l'actualité cette séance de QAG comme
question au gouver
per au élus de contrôler l'action de
l'exécutif alors nous allons voir une
rétrospective des séquences les plus
marquantes de cette automne hiver nous
sommes fin septembre la question de la
vie chè et le sujet central de cette
rentrée 2023 sur fond de crise
énergétique et de hausse des
prix la parole est à monsieur le
Président chassne pour le groupe
GDR pridente madame la Première ministre
la situation sociale de notre pays a
atteint un seuil d'alerte sans pareil
elle est explosive malgré cela le
président de la République a une
nouvelle fois versé dans
l'autoatisfaite nous expliquant que ça
pourrait être pire dans le même temps
Bruno Le Maire en a encore à quander
quelques efforts aux uns et aux autres
sans rien obtenir et pour cause vous
tremblez à l'idée de contraindre
l'urgence c'est pourtant sous vos yeux
40 % des étudiants déclarent renoncer à
des soins 42 % des Français au SMIG se
privent d'un repas par jour près d'un
enfant sur C est touché par la pauvreté
plus violente encore et la situation
subie par les habitants et habitants des
territoires dit d'outrem allant pour
certains jusqu'à être privé du droit
fondamental à l'eau potable comme l'a
rappelé mon collègue Fabien Roussel la
question sociale celle de la vie chè et
la question de la rentrée la question
centrale madame la Première ministre
n'ajoutez pas de la colère au désespoir
agissez avant une nouvelle explosion
sociale entendrez-vous enfin enfin nos
proposition j'ai une
conviction la solution durable pour le
pouvoir d'achat c'est l'emploi cette
conviction c'est celle de mon
gouvernement et je sais qu'elle est
largement partagée sur sur les bands de
icycle y compris dans votre groupe alors
depuis 6 ans nous menons des réformes
courageuses qui donnent des résultats 2
millions d'emplois ont été créés des
usines ouvrent à nouveau et le taux de
chômage est au plus bas depuis 40 ans je
suis d'accord avec vous monsieur le
Président chassigne certaines situations
restent choquantes et il faut que le
travail paye mieux je pense notamment au
temps partiel subis je pense à certains
métiers essentiels encore souspayés les
caissières les agents d' entretien et
puis il est intolérable que certains
soient condamnés à passer l'ensemble de
leur vie professionnelle au SMIC sans
aucune perspective de carrière et puis
j'ajoute que nous agissons pour le
pouvoir d'achat de tous depuis ce le
début de cette période d'inflation avec
les boucliers tarifaires les remises
carburant avec la revalorisation des
petites retraites avec la
déconjugalisation de l'âche à partir du
1er octobre je note qu'aucune de ces
mesures n'a été votée par votre groupe
et cet effort financier exceptionnel
nous l'avons porté en responsabilité
mais en demandant à tous les acteurs de
prendre leur part c'est notamment le
sens cette année de la taxation des
rentes des des énergéticiens et monsieur
le Président chassigne vous m'interrogez
en particulier sur la situation de nos
concitoyens des outresmèes c'est le cœur
des mesures structurelles que j'ai
annoncé le 18 juillet dernier à l'issue
du comité interministériel des outrem
avec la réforme de l'octroi de M des
mesures pour le prix des carburants de
meilleures liaisons dans les Caraïbes
nous agissons concrètement pour nos
compatriotes ultramarins face à la vie
cher je vous remercie madame la Première
ministre inflation alimentaire coût de
la rentrée hausse des carburants selon
une récente étude de l'INC 9 millions de
Français sont en situation de privation
matérielle 42 % des plus précaires
auraient supprimé un repas il est urgent
d'agir pour les aider chaque jour dans
nos permanences nous entendons des
situations de détresse des difficultés à
les fins de mois et les associations
d'aide alimentaires nous alertent elles
sont débordées l'énorme inflation de
produits alimentaire augmente la
pauvreté une aide ciblée fut promise par
le président puis enterrée à plusieurs
reprises le chèque alimentaire nous
demandons sa mise en place immédiate
pour les ménages les plus modestes les
travailleurs et les petites retraites
quand allez-vous le mettre en place il
faut aussi penser à notre jeunesse
remettre le repas à 1 € pour les
cantines pour les étudiants et augmenter
les bourses pour financer ces mesures le
groupe lot a proposé des économies comme
la baisse des dépenses pour les cabinets
de conseil
Minch par exemple ou autre
l'augmentation des taxes sur les méga
profits et une mission flash sur les 180
milliards d'aide annuelle aux
entreprises madame la Première ministre
quelle nouvelles mesur allez-vous
prendre en urgence maintenant pour aider
nos concitoyens qui souffrent alors je
le redis monsieur le Président Pancher
je mesure pleinement les difficultés de
certains de nos concitoyens face à une
inflation forte depuis plusieurs mois
notamment sur les prix alimentaires et
alors que les prix des carburant ont
fortement augmenté ces dernières
semaines des difficultés dans l'Hexagone
comme dans les outremers où les Français
sont confrontés à la vie cher dans ce
contexte monsieur le Président il faut
le dire mon gouvernement a protégé plus
qu'aucun autre gouvernement en Europe je
pense au bouclier tarifaire qui a limité
la hausse des prix du gaz et et de
l'électricité je pense à la remise
carburant puis à l'indemnité carburant
travailleur je pense aussi à la
revalorisation des petites retraite qui
entre en vigueur à partir de ce mois-ci
et qui permettra à 1,7 millions de nos
concitoyens de toucher en moyenne 600 €
supplémentaires par an je pense enfin à
l'indexation sur l'inflation de toutes
les prestations sociales et des
retraites qui sera reconduite en 2024
cela représente un effort de 20
milliards d'euros l'année prochaine
monsieur le Président Pancher face aux
difficultés des Français nous allons
continuer à agir comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République nous allons
reconduire l'indemnité carburant pour
les Français qui travaillent et qui ont
besoin de leur voiture c'est une aide de
100 € qui accompagnera les plus modestes
et les classes moyennes c'est
l'équivalent d'une remise de 20 centimes
d'euros par litre vous m'interrogez sur
les étudiants je rappelle que nous
prolongeons les repas à 1 € pour les
étudiants boursiers tous les étudiants
en difficulté que nous augmentons nous
aurons doublé le montant des aides aux
banques alimentaires en 2023 par rapport
à 2021 et nous allons augmenter le fond
alimentation durable pour permettre à
chacun d'accéder à une alimentation de
qualité mais dans ce contexte monsieur
le Président Pancher chacun doit prendre
sa part et nous devons utiliser tous les
leviers à notre disposition c'est
pourquoi je réunirai tout à l'heure les
tous les acteurs de la filière des
carburants ils savent que nous attendons
de leur part
une mobilisation exceptionnelle à la
hauteur de l'enjeu je leur passerai des
messages simples baisser les prix faire
plus de transparence sur les marges et
aider les Français à trouver les
meilleurs prix près de chez eux vous
voyez monsieur le Président Pancher face
à l'inflation mon gouvernement agit
chacun doit prendre sa part et je sais
pouvoir compter sur votre soutien pour
le pouvoir d'achat des Français je vous
remercieme cette rentrée coûte bien cher
au français 11,3 % de hausse des coûts
des fournitures scolaires si seulement
cela ne se cantonnait qu'au crayon et au
cahers mais l'inflation grimpe et le
pouvoir d'achat des Français diminue et
sur ce dernier point vous êtes les
grands fautif votre récente proposition
de revente à perte de carburant
transformé en précoutant démontre
d'ailleurs la déconnexion totale du
gouvernement les distributeurs l'ont
d'ailleurs refusé mais rassurez-vous les
Français ne fuiront pas s'ils ne peuvent
plus prendre leur voiture le train non
plus avez-vous seulement conscience de
l'augmentation démesurée du prix du
billet cette rentrée c'est finalement un
énième confinement pour les Français à
la seule différence qui ne craineent
plus la covid mais la ruine quant aux
factures d'électricité d'énergie les
tarifs régulés de l'électricité ont
augmenté de 10 % ce premier routte pour
les particuliers mais également pour les
petites entreprises facture qui je leur
rappelle ont quand même plus que doublé
depuis 2021 du fait de votre obstination
à accepter le le mode européen de
fixation des prix de l'électricité sans
ces règles contraires aux intérêts de la
France Les Français verraent leur
facture annuelle baissé d'en moyenne 5
100 € monsieur le ministre que
répondez-vous aux Français qui manque en
moyenne de 588 € pour renouer avec les
loisirs et une vie globalement plus
confortable et à ceux qui ne peuvent
plus se déplacer se chauffer souffler un
peu et construire leur avenir décemment
madame la députée angélique r Je ne
crois sincèrement pas que les solutions
du rassemblement national soient les
bonnes contre
l'inflation l'inflation elle est tirée
vous le savez comme moi par les prix de
l'énergie les prix du gaz et des prix du
pétrole baisser la TVA sur les prix du
pétrole c'est tout simplement alimenter
la consommation d'énergie fossile c'est
faire la politique de producteur nous ne
sommes pas producteurs de pétrole votre
proposition de baisse de la TVA sur
l'essence c'est 10 milliards d'euros
c'est le prix d'un réacteur nucléaire et
bien avec cette majorité nous préférons
investir dans l'énergie nucléaire et
dans l'indépendance énergétique du pays
que de financer la politique de
restriction de production des pays pays
producteur nous voulons aussi aider ceux
qui travaillent nous allons mettre en
place une indemnité carburant transport
elle sera mise en place et j'espère que
vous la voterz au 1er janvier 2024 100 €
par véhicule chois une économie de 20
centimes d'euros par litre de carburant
pour tout ceux qui travaillent le combat
contre l'inflation c'est un combat de
tous les jours un combat qui nous
mobilise avec Olivier Grégoire avec le
ministre de l'Industrie sans cesse nous
obtenons des résultats nous continuerons
à mener ce combat je ne crois pas aux
solution de terme du rassemblement
national les nôtres qui visent
l'indépendance énergétique de la nation
et avoir des prix deélectricité qui sont
fondés sur le coût de production moyen
de nos réacteurs nucléaires nous
paraissent les seules solutions viables
sur le long
terme lors de cette séance de septembre
le sujet du harcèlement scolaire marque
également les questions au gouvernement
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
annonce une lutte prioritaire contre ce
qu'il qualifie de fléo extrait de séance
AR
humiliation et attouchement ces
agissements ont bousillé ma vie d'enfant
et d'adolescente j'ai pu me reconstruire
et construire une famille formidable
mais jamais je n'oublierai ces heures de
souffrance et de détresse j'ai pensé à
une période dénoncer ses agissement cela
fait maintenant plus de 40 ans c'est
loin mais
indélibile cette jeune fille c'était moi
et je ne crois pas être la seule sur ces
bans à avoir été victime de harcèlement
un enfant sur quatre en est victime
combien parle le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame intime tue enfoui parfois
toute une vie le harcèlement scolaire
est un drame qui porte mal son nom car
il ne s'arrête pas en vérité au mur de
l'école il continue après les cours au
foot ou à la danse il revient par
message ou sur les réseaux sociaux la
nuit il hant les rêves qui deviennent
des cauchemars il a droit de
partout c'est un drame qui se niche dans
l'anodin une violence qui ne réclame pas
de coup une blessure qui ne se part pas
de sang je voudrais vous lire aussi ces
mots d'enfant qu' l'exprime si bien le
harcèlement c'est comme l'uranium ça
brûle de l'intérieur le harcèlement ça
commence par une étincelle ça finit par
un incendie maman ce n'est pas pour rire
que j'ai voulu mourir j'aurais voulu
lire enfin les mots de tous ceux qui se
sont donnés la mort avant de parler qui
avant de parler ont dû crier dans leur
tête mais le silence les a emporté il
n'est rien de pire que de ne pas parler
sauf peut-être de parler et de ne pas
être entendu Nicolas comme dans d'autres
a parleré n'a pas été entendu en parlant
de honte vous avez mis les mots justes
monsieur le ministre sur la réaction
indigne de notre Académie je sais que
vous avez à cœur que cette réaction
partout change mais pouvez-vous nous
dire concrètement les actes que vous
entendez mettre à ces mots pour partout
partout les combat remci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur
Gabri ministre de l'éducation nationale
et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée Virginie lanlot Marion 13 ans
et vael 11 ans Dina 14 ans
ambre 11 ans Lucas 13 ans Thib 10 ans
Chanel 12 ans Marie 15 ans
linset 13 ans Nicolas 15 ans ces noms ce
sont ceux d'enfants enlevés à leurs
parents ce sont ceux d'élèves enlevés à
leurs enseignants ce sont ceux de jeunes
enlevés à leur pays par un fléau le
harcèlement scolaire ce fléo il ne
connaît pas de frontières ce fléo il tue
et quand quand il ne tue pas par la mort
il tue la confiance en soi de jeunes qui
ne demande qu'à s'aimer et à aimer les
autres madame la députée j'ai fait dès
ma nomination au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
ma priorité absolue et je le dis de
manière très claire je ne reculerai
devant rien je ne reculerai devant rien
pour mieux prévenir je ne reculerai
devant rien pour que la peur change de
camp je ne reculerai devant rien pour
que la honte change de
camp nous avons d'ors et déjà commencé à
agir avec des décisions importantes qui
ont été prises cet été sur les sanctions
à l'endroit des harceleurs demain la
première ministre présentera et nous
serons à ses côtés le plan
interministériel de lutte contre le
harcèlement pour aller plus loin mieux
prévenir mieux détecter mieux réagir
nous sommes engagés sur ce sujet nous
avons appelé à un électrochoc et je
constate que l'électrochoc a commencé
oui la peur doit changer de camp oui
nous dev devons être plus efficace dans
la lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
c'est ce que nous devons à tous les
élèves de France c'est ce que nous
devons à toutes les familles de France
c'est ce que nous devons à l'école de la
République et c'est ce que nous devons à
notre
nation début octobre un sujet fait la
Une surgit d'un coup les punaises de lit
s'invitent en séance publique de quoi
donner lieu à un échange au vitriol
entre Mathilde Panau chef de fil des
députés insoumis et le gouvernement qui
de son côté assure avoir pris toutes les
mesures nécessaires pour contrer la
psychose
extrait madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre une vague de panique
saisit le pays les punaises de lit
prolifèrent dans tous les lieux du
quotidien les hôpitaux écoles foyer de
travailleurs maisons de retraite les
prisons les trains ou même les salles de
cinéma elles font vivre un calvaire aux
millions de nos concitoyens infestés
elles leur font perdre le sommeil
provoque de la paranoïa et les isole
socialement les punaises de l sont un
problème national de santé publ mais
vous n'avez rien fait en 2017 il y avait
200000 lieux infestés j'ai alerté vous
m'avez rionné vous n'avez rien fait en
2019 il y avait 540000 sites infestés
nous avons manifesté pétitionner
désinsectiser des logements déposer une
résolution pour exiger un plan d'urgence
vous m'avez riononné vous n'avez rien
fait en 2020 il y avait 950000 sites
infestés nous avons interpellé le
gouvernement sur l'urgence à agir vous
m'avez riononné vous n'avez rien fait
rien ou presque un numéro vert et une
plateforme fantôme qui a depuis disparu
en 2022 il y avait 1,1 million de sites
infestés vous avez agi et menti avec un
plan interministériel sans aucune mesure
contraignante et un observatoire annoncé
qui n'a jamais vu le jour madame la
Première ministre 6 ans après c'est
votre inaction qui est largement
responsable de cette situation explosive
plus vous attendez plus cette situation
sitution devient incontrôlable quand
allez-vous enfin interdire les produits
chimiques inefficaces quand 90 % des
punaises ont développé des résistances
quand allez-vous enfin cesser de livrer
les citoyens à eux-mêmes et à la
voracité des entreprises privées nous
exigeons un service public de la
désinsectisation gratuit efficace garant
de la santé et de l'environnement madame
la Première ministre ces petits insectes
répandent le désespoir dans notre pays
faut-il attendre que Matignon soit
infesté pour qu'enfin vous réagissiez il
y a des sujets qui ne devrai pas prêter
à la polémique et au
diffusions un peu de dessence madame la
Présidente alors oui les punaises de lit
sont une angoisse pour nos concitoyens
qui craignent d'y être confronté c'est
un véritable calvaire pour ceux qui sont
touchés l'infestation d'un logement peut
devenir un enfer pour celles et ceux qui
y habitent et les solutions pour s'en
débarrasser peuvent être coûteuses sur
ce sujet il ne devrait pas y avoir de
clivage il devrait y avoir une
détermination collective pour agir alors
madame la Présidente Panau pourquoi une
fois de plus restez-vous dans l'outrance
pourquoi ne dites-vous pas pourquoi ne
dites-vous pas qu'il y a un an et demi
en mars 2022 le plan interministériel de
lutte contre les punaises de lit porté
par les ministères de la transition
écologique du logement et de la Santé a
marqué l'attention du gouvernement à ce
phénomène et apporter des premières
réponses ce plan c'est d'abord de la
sensibilisation pour mieux pour mieux
repérer les infestations et informer
particuliers et professionnels concernés
c'est aussi un accompagnement de la
filière de lutte contre les nuisibles
pour offrir de meilleurs traitements et
disposer de professionnels formés et
reconnus c'est en effet une meilleure
observation du phénomène avec un
observatoire qui est en cours de
création mesdames et messieurs les
députés les punaises de lit ont infesté
la plupart des grandes villes du monde
les études nous montrent que leur
prolifération est liée au voyage
touristique et à la résistance aux
insecticides pour autant nous sommes
déterminés à continuer à agir et
amplifier notre action et une réunion
avec l'ensemble des ministères concernés
se tiendra dans les prochains jours et
la majorité présidentielle a engagé un
travail pour trouver des réponses de
long terme sur la détection
l'infestation et l'accompagnement des
touché une réflexion qui devrait pouvoir
rassembler largement dans cet hémicycle
alors travaillons ensemble trouvons des
solution ensemble je vous
remercie lors de cette séance du 3
octobre on retient aussi un échange
entre la gauche et la majorité
présidentielle sur Mayotte la situation
dans ce petit territoire ultramarin
proche de Madagascar est très critique
en raison des privations drastiques
d'eau potable que subissent les
habitants de Lille de quoi donner lieu à
une passe d'arme moratoire entre
l'écologiste Sandrine Rousseau et le
ministre Géral
armanin laissez-moi vous proposer un
exercice de fiction imaginez la ville de
Strasbourg 270000 habitants à peu près
privé d'eau 2 jours sur trois imaginez
que lorsque l'eau coule en fin du
robinet elle soit maronnase qu'elle
donne la diarrhée imaginez que des
enfants en aille plus à l'école faute
d'eau imaginez-vous dans l'impossibilité
de vous laver de jour sur 3 et pour
boire les habitants de cette ville
doivent acheter des packs d'eau entre 6
et 10 € qui font l'objet de spéculation
et peuvent se revendre encore plus cher
tout cela se passe à Mayotte et c'est
loin Mayotte très loin pourtant maotte
c'est la France bien sûr on peut dire
qu'il s'agit d'une sécheresse
exceptionnelle mais ce serait voir
qu'une parti du problème ce dont il
s'agit ici c'est bien d'une crise de
l'abandon par l'État faute d'entre
retient 40 % des fuites d'eau du réseau
pas de traitement des déchets ni de
lutte contre la pollution aucune
démarche d'association des populations
locales pour trouver une solution pas
d'anticipation par les recherches la
situation n'est pas nouvelle 29 % des
résidences à Mayotte n'ont pas accès à
l'eau potable contre moins de 1 % dans
l'Hexagone sans eau tout est menacé bien
sûr le ministre des outresmèes a proposé
35 millions d'investissements d'
di du coou de l'autoroute
à69 quelques bouteilles d'eau 350
millions investis on ne sait pas quand
dépensement du dénis à la fin de
l'incompétence nous ne l'accepterions
pas une seconde dans l'Hexagone pourquoi
l'acceptonsnous à Mayotte ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre pour le
gouvernement les Maor sont-ils des
Français comme les
autres je
[Applaudissements]
vousci eur et
des Mesdames et Messieurs les député
madame la présidente madame Rousseau
imaginez une députée qui POS une
question à maillot sans jamais s'y être
rendu madame la
députée s'il vous plaît votre
intervention votre
intervention
démagogique de comparer les 50000
bouteilles d'eau que distribue l'armée
française en ce momentil vous plat
silence de comparer les difficultés
qu'on n compat Maé quand nous défendions
ici même la possibilité d'avoir un
projet de lo spécifique que votre groupe
politique a toujours combattu et de
comparer les difficultés que connaissent
nos amis Maor don lequel le gouvernement
fait des efforts essentiel parce qu'il
n'y a pas de Na fratique à maotte pour
finalement servir vos intérêts
politiques et sans vous être rendu
auprès des
Maoris madame les député travaillez
plutôt avec nous pour fournir à la
population maoraaise sa véritable
autonomie en effet en eau elle qui
connaît sans doute la plus belle terre
de la République mais qui connaî
malheureusement le retrait et les enjeux
politiciens madame dont vous êtes
manifestement
l'incarnation je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre madame
rousse monsieur le ministre imaginez un
ministre qui parle sécheresse sans
jamais avoir compris le réchauffement
climatique monsieur le
ministre madame la députée vous ne
voulez pas voir que l'un des problèmes
Maillotte c'est sa surpopulation et que
lorsque nous nous battons pour des
opérations de reconduite à la frontière
lorsque nous nous battons pour la
scolarisation des enfants lorsque nous
nous battons pour construire un deuxè
centre hospitalier vous votez contre
toutes les décisions qui concernent
Mayotte et aujourd'hui vous voulez nous
faire croire alors que les Maoris
réclament la fermeté de la République
que vous êtes de leur côté mais venez
dans 15 jours venez dans 2 mois venez
dans 3 mois quand nous allons tous les
mois avec le ministre desameot nous
accompagnez sortez de Paris et allez à
mamouzou à l'approche de l'hiver on
s'inquiète sur les ban de gauche du sort
des plus fragiles la situation précaire
de nombreux étudiants et celle des
enfants à la rue préoccupe la
représentation
nationale en 2017 le candidat en marche
à la présidence nous promettait la
construction de 60000 logements
étudiants et de ne plus avoir personne
qui dorment dans les rues sans surprise
cette promesse est non
tenue depuis 2017 c'est devenu
l'habitude les promesses non tenue et
les 493 qui s'enchaînent de semaine en
semaine
et et même si on ne s'attend à rien on
est quand même déçu
indigne voilà le mot qui me vient à
l'esprit quand je pense aux conditions
de vie et d'étude de nos jeunes indigne
quand h logements sur 100 sont vides
mais que les étudiants dorment dans la
rue ou dans leur
voiture indigne quand le cru ne peut
proposer aux étudiants qu'un logement
sur 16 demandes en moyenne indigne quand
12 % des étudiants renoncent à leur
projet d'étude faute de
logement crise du logement baisse des
aPL hausse des prix de l'énergie servir
les plus riches pour déshabiller les
plus pauvres encore et
toujours les étudiants ne veulent plus
de vos mesurettes madame la ministre ils
veulent s'émanciper vivre dignement et
de manière autonome
mais surtout ils attendent que le
gouvernement tienne enfin ses promesses
en assurant à chacun un logement alors
madame la ministre quel dispositif
d'urgence mettez-vous en place pour ne
laisser plus aucun étudiant dormir
dehors c'est une question de dignité
bravo je vous remercie pour la question
parce que ça me donne l'occasion
effectivement de dire ce que ce
gouvernement et cette majorité fait pour
les étudiants de façon générale et en
particulier dans le cadre du logement
collèg la parole s'il vous plaît le
logement étudiant effectivement
actuellement comme tous les logements
aujourd'hui connaî une crise je vous
vois pas mais et ce logement étudiant on
avait un plan de 60000 logements 30000
logements ont été réalisés depuis 2017
aujourd'hui le logement étudiant fait
partie d'une crise de foncier et nous
sommes en train d'identifier avec le
ministre du Logement le foncier
disponible pour pouvoir continuer cet
engagement de passer de 30000 logements
déjà réalisé aux 60000 logements et puis
c'est travaillé dans de bonnes
conditions pour les étudiants vous
l'avez dit et donc dans ce cadre là
c'est 12000 logements sur les 175000
logements du Cruise qu'il reste à
rénover et nous avons déjà planifié
cette rénovation de ces 12000 logements
4000 sont en cours actuellement et 8000
sont planifiés jusqu'à 2027 et puis je
vous rappelle que nous avons gelé les
loyers de Cruise depuis 4 ans nous avons
augmenté les app
et que cette majorité a gelé aussi pour
les conditions étudiants les droits
d'inscription mais aussi beaucoup les
les toutes les les droits d'inscription
effectivement et les restaurations et
nous avons mis sur la table pour cette
rentrée un demiilliards de plus sur la
vie étudiante en particulier sur cette
première étape des bourses c'est cette
majorité qui depuis 10 ans a fait le
plus sur la réforme des bourses et sur
l'augmentation des bourses étudiantes en
ce moment dans notre pays qui se tient
fièrement parmi les premières économies
du monde une réalité sombre et
insupportable ébranle nos consciences
des milliers d'appels au 115 restent
sans réponse laissant plus de 2800
enfants sans abri des enfants des
enfants exposés au froid à l'insécurité
à la précarité à Lyon et ailleurs des
citoyens des enseignants et des parents
d'élèves s'organisent goûter solidaire
occupation d'école il comble l'espace
que vous n'arrivez pas à occuper faute
de moyens l'Abbé Pierre disait le
contraire de la misère ce n'est pas la
richesse le contraire de la misère c'est
le partage ce que nous voulons ça n'est
pas la charité nous voulons du travail
et des logements dignes pour tous vous
vous donnez des milliards aux
entreprises chaque année sans
contrepartie et vous menez une politique
qui appauvrit les gens qui ne sont déjà
pas bien riches baisse des aPL
précarisation des chômeurs casse du Code
du travail coût budgétaire y compris
dans certains services sociaux vous êtes
allé jusqu'à criminaliser l'occupation
des logements vacants alors évidemment
les budgets alloués à l'hébergement
d'urgence n'ont jamais été aussi haut
mais parce que la situation n'a jamais
été aussi
catastrophique il y a 2822 enfants qui
dorment dans les rues de notre pays ce
que nous ne voulons ce n'est pas la
charité mais il y a urgence la semaine
dernière nous avons voté l'augmentation
des places d'hébergement d'urgence en
commission des finances avec des députés
de tout bord politique monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple vous
engagez-vous à maintenir la création de
ces places dans le budget final que vous
allez faire adopter malgré le 493 je
vous remercie aucun gouvernement aucun
gouvernement n'a créé autant de places
d'hébergement d'urgence aucun
gouvernement nous sommes aujourd'hui à
plus de 203000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence et nous continuons encore à
les
augmenter avec le plan logement d'abord
approuvé par toutes les associations ces
440000 personnes à la rue qui ont
retrouvé un logement et nous continuons
aujourd'hui ce travail ce matin j'ai eu
l'occasion d'annoncer 500 postes
supplémentaires 500 postes
supplémentaires un/ers des effectifs
madame les député pour la veille sociale
le 115 que vous évoquez les marodes que
vous évoquez aussi également nous 2 ans
50 dans l'hébergement d'urgence ça ne
nous va pas augmenter les places
d'hébergement d'urgence ça ne nous va
pas nous voulons trouver des solution
pour qu'il puisse trouver un logement et
c'est ça que nous faisons actuellement
et c'est pour ça que nous remontons ces
effectifs là avec des solutions de
logement à la
clé début novembre la France est touchée
par des tempêtes de vaste ampleur puis
des inondations frappe le département du
Pas decalais de quoi donner lieu à de
très nombreuses questions sur les
conséquences les dégâts humains et
matériels de ces catastrophes naturelles
extrait madame la Première ministre si
dans le Pas de calis des milliers
d'habitants sont sinistrés sous les eaux
les Finistériens ont été durement
éprouvés par la tempête Karon son
exceptionnelle violence les dégâts
considérables subis ont fait remonter le
souvenir dévastateur de l'ouragan de 87
TPE PME et surtout agriculteur payent un
lourd tribut le président de la
République conscient de la gravité de la
situation s'est rendu dans ma
circonscription auprès des producteurs
de fraises de plugastel pour porter un
engagement fort le chef de l'État a
promis de décréter l'état de catastrophe
naturelle partout où on pourra le faire
pouvez-vous nous expliquer comment la
tempête 40 peut-être classée en
catastrophe naturelle car la loi a exclu
de fait les tempêtes du régime des
catastrophes et des calamités agricoles
pour tout vous dire ce que le président
a annoncé n'est pas clair un grand
nombre d'exploitant sont très inquiets
attendent des précisions concrètes
concernant les promesses présidentielles
pour ne pas compromettre leur activité
la survie de leur exploitation les
agriculteurs ont besoin d'un
accompagnement d'urgence pour la casse
pour les pertes qui sera concerné par
l'état de catastrophe sous quelles
conditions quel délai madame la Première
ministre les Finistériens préoccupés
attendent de votre part une réponse
claire et précise madame la députée
avant de vous répondre peut-être d'abord
saluer le dispositif d'alerte qui a pu
être mis en place pour la première fois
dans notre pays dispositif fr alerte et
qui a permis quand même à 98 % de la
population concernée d'être non
seulement alerté sur les risques liés à
la tempête mais sur les gestes à
réaliser pour pouvoir se protéger et
nous pouvons dire que sans ce dispositif
d'alerte le bilan humain aurait sans
doute été beaucoup plus important
s'agissant des agriculteurs ils recevont
tout le soutien évidemment des assureurs
qui sont mobilisés mais également de
l'État partout ce sera nécessaire croyez
en la détermination de l'état pas que
sur le coup de la tempête mais aussi
dans la durée c'est ce que nous leur
devons madame la Première ministre dans
le dans le fin myère nous en avons connu
des tempêtes pour tous celle qui vient
de dévaster la pointe de la Bretagne et
le nord-ouest de la France avait un nom
siaran pour nous habitants de la 8e
circonscription du Finistère il restera
un autre prénom un autre nom et surtout
un visage associé à cette tempête celui
de Frédéric Despo agent d'énédis décédé
en travaillant à rétablir l'électricité
pour des milliers de Bretons il avait 46
ans et 3 enfants
originaire de hoch il venait dans le
cadre de la force d'intervention rapide
avec de nombreux agents enedis pour
réparer le réseau électrique
complètement dévasté je souhaite et vous
l'avez fait aussi en mon nom et au nom
des habitants de ma circonscription lui
rendre hommage ainsi qu'à sa famille son
son sens du devoir pardon nous honore je
veux aussi remercier et surtout
féliciter le préfet du Finistère et ses
services tous les agents publics et tous
les élus des collectivités locales les
forces de l'ordre les pompiers et la
sécurité civile ainsi que les citoyens
qui ont fait preuve d'une solidarité
incroyable alors si cette crise a été
bien anticipée et bien gérée elle nous
interroge comment compte-il améliorer
son plan de gestion de crise et
d'adaptation pour améliorer la
résilience des réseaux et leur capacité
à rester opérationnelle alors vous
l'avez dit ces tempêtes ces dérèglements
climatiques on sait qu'elles vont être
amenées à se
reproduire si nos opérateurs de réseau
ont été très mobilisés ces derniers
jours et je le soulligne encore y
compris s'agissant d'énédis au prix de
la vie d'un des agents qui était
intervenus en Bretagne nous devons
effectivement mieux anticiper encore ces
tempête et nous préparer à faire face à
des vents violents comme nous l'avons
connu ces derniers jours mais aussi à
des inondations et j'ai une pensée pour
tous les habitants du Pas de Calais qui
vivent actuellement des inondations
aussi
exceptionnelles à partir du 21 novembre
l'organisation des questions au
Gouvernement change une séance vient
s'ajouter le mercredi plus courte que
celle du mardi c'est l'expérimentation
souhaitée par la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale qui a voulu
redynamiser ses questions au
gouvernement alors ce jour-là la mort
tragique de Thomas 16 ans tué à crépool
dans la Drome fait la une des questions
d'actualité la parole est à Madame
Emmanuelle Antoine pour le groupe les
républicains ce weekend dans la nuit du
18 au 19 novembre dans ma
circonscription la vie d'un adolescent
de 16 ans a été emporté Thomas a
succombé au coup qui lui ont été infligé
ce jeune avait toute une vie devant lui
il lui resté tout à vivre ses joies ses
amours ses peines ses espoirs tout cela
lui a été enlevé Thomas avait une
famille des parents aimants des amis
proches c'est vers eux que vont mes
pensées Thomas n'a pas eu droit à une
minute de silence je tiens donc à lui
rendre hommage dans cet hémicycle temple
de notre République pour que laés ation
nationale témoigne unanimement de son
soutien envers sa
famille ce weekend une bande de jeune a
fait irruption dans un moment festif
pour en découdre lors d'un bal organisé
par le comité des fêes de la commune de
crépool ils ont violemment attaqué à
l'arme blanche les participants de cette
soirée 16 autres personnes ont été
blessées et deux sont en urgence absolue
à l'issue de ce drame je leur adresse
tout mon soutien pour tous les jeunes
présents ce qui devait être un moment de
fête a finalement été le mouroir de leur
insouciance juvénile pour tous les
participants la convivialité de cet
événement a effroyablement laissé place
au deuil et à la désolation que partage
tout notre territoire la violence a
encore frappé dans notre pays cette
violence qui ne cesse de meurtrir et
d'endeuiller cette violence qui
gangrainene tout et que l'on ne parvient
pas à enrayer nous devons unanimement la
condamner notre République doit être
forte oui elle doit avoir les moyens de
faire face aux agresseurs et se montrer
ferme dans ses condamnations pour que
des vies cessent d'être ôté des familles
entière d'être endeuillé et pour que nos
jeunes puissent vivre leur jeunesse tout
simplement pour la mesure dont vous avez
fait preuve en posant cette question
oui la vie enlevée de ce gosse de 16 ans
méritait à l'évidence un moment de
silence et de recueillement il a
immédiatement été substitué par un
moment de polémique j'ai noté d'ailleurs
que
dans la question j'ai noté d'ailleurs
que dans la question précédente on
évoquait le mot de Razia il n'y a pas de
hasard il n'y a que des rendez-vous les
rendez-vous du malheur que vous honorez
qu'il s'agisse de la petite Lola qu'il
s'agisse du petit Clément une dernière
chose s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
une dernière
chose les auteurs de ces faits seront
jugés par une cour d'assise
composé d'un jury populaire comme le
sont tous les crimes de sang et ce sont
des Français comme vous comme moi qui
rendront la justice qui n'est pas
laxiste qui est sévère de plus en plus
sévère depuis 20
ans ce même jour les députés de la
majorité comme de l'opposition
interrogent le gouvernement sur les
violences de plus en plus nombreuses
contre les élus de la République alors
que se tient le jour même le 105e
congrès des maires de France
extrait 40 démissions par mois 40
démission par mois et le sentiment pour
les maires de France qui tiennent
congrès que l'État les ignore que l'État
quelquefois les méprise un mépris qui se
traduit par l'absence notable du
président Macron à cette rencontre de
tous ceux qui sont le cœur battant de la
République tous les jours nos élus sont
engagés sur le terrain pour répondre aux
exigences de l'État qui s'accumule et
trop souvent
nos élus locaux sont empêchés parfois
humiliés souvent enququiné plutôt
qu'accompagné pourtant les maires
tiennent la baraque France gilet jaune
covid inflation émeut les maires n'ont
pas manqué face aux crises ils sont
restés à porter d'engueulade sans
disposer des moyens pour répondre au
mots de nos concitoyens et des outils
pour recoudre une république fracturée
dernier rempart républicain urgentiste
d'une France qui va mal nos mes ont le
moral en berne madame la ministre le
temps vous le savez n'est pas au
discours ou à la
calinothérapie comment le gouvernement
envistage-t-il au-delà des violences
faites aux élus de faire respecter les
communes l'engagement de nos mères est
précieux ils sont en première ligne du
phénomène d'atteinte aux élus vous avez
raison de le rappeler leurs engagements
leur engagement exceptionnel
et mérite une protection exceptionnelle
c'est le fait c'est ce que fait le
gouvernement au travers des dispositifs
spécifiques d'un plantion financé à
hauteur de 5 millions d'euros pour 2024
force de sécurité intérieure magistrat
association ont été mobilisé mais il
faut aussi donner au maire des leviers
d'action le gouvernement s'engage à
garantir des dotations financières péren
à simplifier les conditions d'exercice
de leur mandat à développer le droit de
dérogation à la main des préfets au
soutien des initiatives local la
reconnaissance du travail des maires
c'est aussi le travail engagé autour du
statut de l'élu vous même et la députée
violette spilbou avait engagé ce travail
dans le cadre d'une d'une mission
parlementaire la Convention nationale de
la démocratie locale organisée par
Dominique fort ma collègue et l'AMF
s'est tenu le 7 novembre dernier à
vocation à nourrir les réflexions qui se
sont engagés et qui sont engagés par
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat il a
beaucoup pas faire c'est vrai sur ces
sujets pour renforcer le rôle des maires
et leur donner les moyens de conduire
leur mandat dans des conditions à la
hauteur de leur engag
vous êtes mobilisé les associations des
l le son nous sommes mobilisés nous
sommes collectivement mobilisés et nous
pouvons réussir ensemble merci merci
beaucoup madame la
ministre début décembre un sujet domine
le débat public celui de l'immigration
alors que le gouvernement tente
désespérément de faire adopter son
projet de loi si décrié cela donne lieu
en séance publ lors des questions
gouvernement à des échanges au vitriol
dans une ambiance
électrique
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre depuis 18 mois nous avons dans
cet hémicycle au Sénat dans la presse ou
en commission débattu largement de
l'immigration sujet important au
français le débat a bien eu lieu nous y
avons pour notre part largement
participé en cherchant les moyens de
remettre le bon ordre dans le grand
bazar de votre politique migratoire à
régulariser celles et ceux qui
travaillent déjà à remettre en route
l'intégration République WE mais le
texte que le gouvernement sprêté à
défendre très éloigné des positions
d'Emmanuel Macron en 2017 que nous avons
fait par deux fois élire face à
l'extrême droite vous devez vous en
souvenir très éloigné de sa version
initiale de l'ambition même que vous
étiez donné en matière de régularisation
par le travail aveugle à la question de
l'intégration sans équilibre s'agissant
des questions d'éloignement et qui est
menacé gravement d'être inefficace et
inutile il nétait plus qu'un mauvais
texte de loi de police des étrangers le
rejet de ce texte soir Madame la
première ministre c'est votre seul échec
c'est celui de votre Ministre ce n'est
pas la gauche qui vous précipite dans
les bras de la droite qui elle même se
jette dans les bras de l'extrême droite
parce que le pacte funeste c'est celui
noué au Sénat par votre Ministre avec la
droite qui porte le programme du
rassemblement national et pour elle ça
ne sera jamais assez madame la Première
ministre je vous le demande sans
outrance sans cri sans la satisfaction
du spectacle de la chute retirreer ce
texte qui ne satisfait personne avant
d'êtreé sur une pente et sur un
territoire qui n'est pas le vôtre et que
d'autres après vous utiliseraient contre
la République contre l'État de droit
contre la
France je vous
remercie hier vous avez fait un choix
lourd de conséquence pour un coup
politique sans lendemain vous avez mis
de côtés vos convictions vous avez
choisi de mêler vos voix à cell de
l'extrême droite vous avez mis de
côté vous avez mis de côté des décennies
d'histoire du Parti socialiste pour
refuser le débat en vous appuyant sur le
rassemblement national vous étiez un
parti de gouvernement hier vous avez
fait le choix de
l'irresponsabilité hier le en même temps
si cher à Emmanuel Macron a montré ses
limites et s'est soldé par un véritable
camouflé pour votre gouvernement alors
que les Français expriment leur volonté
d'une baisse drastique de l'immigration
dans notre pays comme d'habitude vous ne
les avez pas pas écoué et au contraire
vous avez proposé un texte qui aurait
permis la création de nouvelles filières
d'immigration la répartition de migrants
dans nos campagnes et la régularisation
massive de clandestins il y avait dans
ce texte quelques mesures de bon sens
qu'au rassemblement national nous
réclamons depuis des années je pense en
particulier à celle qui vise à supprimer
les dérogations existantes dans notre
droit qui nous empêche d'expulser un
délinquent étranger si l'on en croit les
courriers reçus par les parlementaires
en fin de semaine dernière
ce genre d'expulsion constitue une
priorité pour votre gouvernement alors
qu'en 6 ans vous n'aurez pas été capable
de vous saisir de ce sujet extrêmement
préoccupant pour nos concitoyens Marine
Le Pen dans son esprit constructif et
sincèrement soucieux de la sécurité des
Français a déposé ce matin un texte
permettant précisément de lever ses
dérogations d'après les déclarations de
nomuxèguesetteosition
de bénéficier d'un soutien transpartisan
alors ma question est la suivante
allez-vous demander son étude dans les
prochains jours je vous
remercie mesdames et messieurs les
députés madame diz s'il y a bien eu en
même temps c'est en même temps entre le
vote du rassemblement national et celui
de
l'anupes Madame
Diaz le N débat d'hier a démontré d'une
chose c'est que vous avez peur du
débat vous n'avez pas voulu parler
d'immigration vous en parlez dans les
meetings dans les marchés sur les
tractes vous en parlez sur les plateaux
de télévision mais vous n'en parlez
jamais devant la représentation
nationale parce que vous avez eu
peur et c'est tellement vrai que votre
belle unité de façade entre les
contraires entre vos amis mélanchonistes
et vous-même entre ceux qui veulent
accueillir tout le monde et ceux qui
veulent accueillir personne
fait que dès le lendemain vous proposez
exactement les mêmes dispositions que le
gouvernement pour lutter contre les
étrangers délinquants trouver
l'erreurci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre madame
Diaz merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous feigz d'ignorer ce
qu'est une motion de rejet très
sincèrement ça n'est pas au niveau et je
pense que les Français continueront de
vous le reprocher mais moi j'ai une
dernière question pour vous monsieur le
ministre qui a peur du débat moi je
pense que c'est vous proposer au
français
référendum je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre vous auriez pu débattre ici et
maintenant plutôt que réclamer un débat
vous auriez pu l'accepter dès
hier vous êtes
incohérent comme d'habitude le
rassemblement national V des problème et
ne veut aucune des solutions vous avez
désarmé nos policiers hier vous avez
désarmé préfet vous désarmez les
Français et vous allez vous réjouir au
prochain fait d'hiver vous faites la
politique vous faites la politique du
dénis et vous faites malheureusement la
politique du pire parce que ce qui vous
intéresse c'est la France qui ne réussit
pas ce qui nous intéresse c'est la
France qui trouve des solutions nous
soutenons nos policiers n gendarmes nous
polici nous soutenons nos préfets vous
vous faites que de la politique
politicienne je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers
collègues le groupe Horizon est
déçu déçu que l'Assemblée nationale a
été privé d'un débat pourtant si
important pour la France et les
Français nous sommes convaincus que ce
texte voté au Sénat et en commission des
lois contient des avancées absolument
nécessaires pour notre pays pour notre
sécurité pour notre souveraineté et plus
encore conform au souit de nos
concitoyens ce sont 86 % des Français
qui sont favorables par exemple à
l'expulsion des délinquants étrangers à
l'issue de leur peine de prison il faut
agir et ce projet est une pierre
indispensable à l'édifice de la
réconciliation entre le discours
politique et l'action publique il donne
les moyens à l'administration et à la
justice de prendre les décisions
nécessairire à la préservation de notre
cohésion
sociale cc qui n'est d'accord sur rien
c'est coalisé pour refuser le débat au
sein de cet hémicycle et j'espère qu'une
majorité de conviction se dégagera pour
adopter un texte de responsabilité
d'efficacité et c'est soucieux de
l'intérêt général que le groupe horizon
et apparenté le
soutiendra sur ce chemin sinueux nous
devons nous nous devons d'être à la
hauteur de notre devoir et de ne pas
jouer avec les fractures de notre pays
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur ma
question est la suivante quel chemin
empruné pour répondre à l'inquiétude
légitime des Français en matière de
politique migratoire après l'adoption de
la motion de rejet préalable
hier je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur géralde darin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des
outres merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs députés monsieur
le député Pradal je veux vous remercier
ainsi que monsieur le rapporteur général
les
rapporteurs madame Martin madame Martin
excusez-moi monsieur le ministre madame
Martin je vous remercie de laisser le
ministre s'exprimer sinon je vous
rappelle à l'ordre sinon je vous
rappelle à
l'ordre monsieur le ministre merci
madame la Présidente je remercie donc
monsieur Pradal votre travail en tant
que rapporteur et tous ceux qui ont
travaillé sur ce texte ainsi que
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois parce que ce texte a été adopté
par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale à une très large
majorité alors que la majorité y est en
majorité relative pourquoi parce que
d'abord vous l'avez dit c'est un texte
qui est soutenu par les Français est-ce
qu'on fait hier une majorité de députés
c'est se mettre d'accord pour que les
Français n'aient pas de débat c'est se
mettre d'accord pour que les Français
n'aient pas le texte qu'ils souhaitent
et c'est se mettre d'accord dans une
coalition en effet des contraires sans
majorité alternative pour que les
Français ne connaissent pas des
solutions contre l'immigration
irrégulière et contre les étrangers
délinquants ce qu'on a fait hier en
votant la Moon de Roger on n'a pas
rejeté le texte puisqu'il est renvoyé en
CMP comme l'a dit madame la Première
ministre on a rejeté le débat dans la
chambre qui est censé débattre on a
rejeté le débat on a fait perdre du
temps au policiers au gendarmes au
préfet au magistrats et on a
finalement désavouer leur travail qui
peut être contre comme je l'ai dit hier
l'examen de réussite français pour avoir
un titre de séjour en France qui peut
s'opposer pour l'expulsion d'étrangers
délinquants qui peut refuser d'interdire
les mineurs dans les centres de
rétention administratif monsieur Pradal
soyons fier de notre travail de notre
conviction ne laissons pas ce qu' une
petite soupe sur leur petit feu nous
divertir nous sommes là parce que nous
sommes conscients que les Français nous
ont confié la responsabilité celle de
porter nos convictions d'être dur contre
l'immigration irrégulière et d'oublier
les attaques personnelles et les
attaques politiciennes merci à vous il
est des moments où il se joue ici bien
plus que de la politique bien plus que
la loi
où se joue finalement l'identité de la
République et l'âme de notre pays alors
que l'extrême droite vient d'annoncer
avoir engrangé une victoire idéologique
majeure et s'apprête à voter votre texte
sur
l'immigration je ne peux pas je ne veux
pas croire chers collègues de la
majorité présidentielle que vous
puissiez toutes et tous cautionner ce
qui a été fait sous la dicté du
gouvernement en commission mixte
paritaire cautionnement pour les
étudiants internationaux retour de la
préférence nationale fin de
l'automaticité du droit du sol quota
restriction regroupement familial
abandon des régularisation par le
travail volonté de réformer l'aide
médicale d'État en 2024 vous avez cédé
surt et vous avez surtout
cédé le sujet mes
chersègues
ce n'est plus la gauche ce n'est plus la
droite ce n'est plus la majorité ce
n'est plus l'opposition c'est le serment
humaniste conclu avec les Françaises et
les Français en 2017 et en 2022 quand
des millions d'entre eux ont choisi de
faire barrage à l'extrême droite raciste
dans notre pays chers collègues soyons
collectivement dig de la dignité des
Français je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
armanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outr
[Musique]
Maes monsieur Lucas madame la Présidente
pardon monsieur Lucas ça vous faisait
moins de peine la semaine dernière
qu'and l'Assemblée nationale se levait
pour vous
applaudir monsieur
Luc en plus d'aller chercher les voix du
Front national vous mentez parce que
dans le texte de la CMP il y a bien la
régularisation des travailleurs des
bétiers en
attention vous mentez parce qu'il y a
bien la fin des mineurs dans les centres
de
rétention et Monsieur Lucas les deux
sénateurs du rassemblement national ont
voté contre le texte du Sénat voilà qu'
jour et aujourd'hui Madame Le Pen
viendraité courourir au secours de la
victoire mais c'est pour voir votre mine
déconfie en ayant voté la motion de
rejet monsieur
Lucas alors oui
oui nous prenons nos
responsabilités et Monsieur Lucas
n'aventez pas n'importe quoi grâce à
l'action de la première ministre et de
la majorité il y a des distinctions
entre ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
ne travaillent pas mais cette
distinction a déjà été faite en 1988 par
Michel Rocard pour le
RMI je vous remercie monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous êtes lamentable nous
n'avons pas de leçon à recevoir de la
part de ceux qui font entrer des
pentiers du programme de Jean-Marie Le
Pen dans la loi nous n'avons pas leçon à
recevoir de ceux qui offre une victoire
historique à l'extrême droite rien ne
vous obliger à convoquer une CMP rien ne
vous obliger à présenter ce texte rejeté
par l'Assemblée nationale vous avez cédé
l'histoire vous regarde elle vous jugera
Sév merci
beaucoup voilà pour ce florilège des
questions au Gouvernement automne
hiivvert c'est la fin de ce numéro des
grands débats on se retrouve très vite
sur LCP pour une autre séance
parlementaire